Virtual Reality is a game changer it's
an expensive occasionally nauseating
game changer that requires you to set
aside a large square of space in your
home but keep still the game changer
well very unlikely to replace
traditional gaming vr gaming is an
extraordinary experience and one that I
highly highly recommend but in saying
that there's some stuff that we found
while playing it this week that you guys
are probably gonna want to know in a
chance so here's our psvr PSA now more
often than not virtual reality is a solo
experience show you've got games like
rigs that throw you in with other people
also wearing VR headsets but more often
than not VR is really a one-person
activity or at least it should be what
it actually is is as Danis put it a
logistical nightmare a phrase I'm
reminded of every time I followed the
system instruction to put on my headset
and then blindly and helplessly feel
around for my headphones and controllers
a feat I consistently fail at which
causes the closest possible person to
yell stop I will do it for you stop
moving you're making it worse I sure
hope you trust whether you get to help
you because chances are extremely high
that you're gonna do something
embarrassing while in VR
if you do manage to get yourself into
the contraption and not tied up and why
is well done you're on to the next
challenge not smashing into the sofa
slash coffee table one of the wonderful
things about VR is how immersive it is
you'll actually feel like you're in the
bat-cave all riding down a hellish
roller coaster you'll believe you can
lean on that table that isn't there and
you'll trust that there is three feet of
clear space in front of you for you to
fling out a Batarang when really your TV
screen is right in front of you and you
just call it a thousand bucks of damage
so you've managed to put your headset on
after clearing enough space and now
you're falling deep down the rabbit hole
before too long you've lost count of how
long you've been playing well the best
reminder is to whip off that headset and
deal with what we've dubbed of the
hangover from what we've experienced the
longer you're under the harder it is to
readapt to the real world after I
completed Batman VR for example I sat at
my desk and my brain was telling me that
everything around me was moving back and
forth ever so slightly it's enough to
make standing immediately after a pipe
dream well we're on the subject of
standing when was the last time you
stood to play a video game I'm gonna bet
it was when you first played Wii Sports
until you realize you could just as
easily get that strike while sitting
comfortably on your couch never then I
never stand unless it's absolutely
required of it turns out standing in the
same place for long periods of time is
really really hard
doubly so if you believe you're in a
metal cage slowly descending into the
dark depths of the ocean that's why we
generally recommend sitting down to play
even if it does make Batman look like
he's impersonating a t-rex not everybody
in the world has trouble with high
intensity rides and not everybody has
problems with motion sickness but for
those of you who do you might want to be
careful with how much you take on in VR
even if you aren't moving around a lot
in game the constant twisting and
turning of your head can produce some
unpleasant results also if you want to
prank your friends I'm told that moving
the PlayStation camera while they're in
VR is a truly sickening experience fun
for you less fun for them then confirm
it is the worst we're still is horror in
VR this might be your cup of tea but I
really can't stress enough how much
playing horror games like Resident Evil
and here they lie in VR really is a
waking nightmare
choose a choice
if you're a daredevil slobs you love to
go to gentleman rush and this will be
right up your alley
otherwise you might be more of a dance
PlayStation VR already has a very hefty
price tag for entry so you want to make
sure you're getting the best games or
experiences you're gonna be hearing that
experiences descriptor a lot in
reference to VR as a lot of the times
these games don't necessarily have what
you see as traditional gameplay invent
take Batman Arkham VR for example I love
the Arkham games for one thing their
mechanics I've always said give me that
fighting system with wire models only
and I'd play it just as much even
without the combat though Batman VR
reminded me that Rocksteady understands
what it means to be Batman Arkham videos
mechanics can be summarized thusly reach
forward with your phantom gauntlets
until you can pick something up
occasionally throw a Batarang and scan
stuff with your bat torch but up all the
experiences are played so far it would
be the one I'd recommend you get
straightaway the one I recommend you
ever get is here they lie because it's
truly truly the worst I definitely back
up that Batman Beyond recommendation but
it's also worth trying out some of the
more obscure demo titles - so you can
hop into the shoes or the weird
disembodied hands of a gangster or scuba
diver it's a more surreal and engaging
experience and I think it can be
articulated without trying it for
yourself so you might not want to drop
several hundred dollars on PlayStation
VR on the gamble that this might be your
thing but if one of your friends has got
one I'd highly recommend going around to
their house and seeing if it is for you
[Music]